the future of french troops in mali is
in doubt as relations with the former
colonial power deteriorate
after france's foreign minister called
mali's military rulers illegitimate the
military called the comments outrageous
and is kicking out the french ambassador
paris has become increasingly frustrated
at the presence of russian mercenaries
in mali to combat armed groups
the russian wagner group stands accused
of plundering mali's natural resources
such as gold and uranium in exchange for
protecting the military government
the isolation of mali such today that
they have only one partner the
mercenaries of wagner group that's all
they can find everyone else wants mali
to return to democracy and the fight
against terrorism in 2013 french forces
repelled armed groups invading mali
almost 10 years on the security
situation has deteriorated dramatically
with thousands killed and millions
displaced by the ongoing fighting in the
largely lawless sahel region
the french military presence is being
increasingly questioned and reviewed by
mali's military junta
last month denmark withdrew around 100
soldiers deployed alongside french and
international troops after the malian
government said they hadn't been invited
the current situation requires respect
for commitment and dialogue on the part
of the malian authorities and the
negative spiral in which they have
engaged can only be detrimental to the
stability of the male itself
but also to the region
since colonel assimi goethe launched two
sequential coups in 2020 and 2021
relations with france have suffered as
the military leaders established
themselves and looked for allies to
support their rule
assad beg al-jazeera